since this video is about Parables let's
start with a
story once upon a time there was a man
with the brain of a
donkey this donkey brained man loved and
I mean loved apples honey crisp
Macintosh pink lady Golden Delicious
Granny Smith it didn't matter he loved
them
all but he hated and I mean hated
trees couldn't stand them couldn't stand
the leaves the bark The Roots he hated
trees so much that he chopped down every
single tree on the entire planet when
people with normal brains pointed out to
him the important fact that apples grow
on trees Mr donkey brains replied heha
not to worry there are plenty of apples
at the
supermarket so after chopping down every
tree in the world he got his apples from
the supermarket until the supermarket
ran out of apples because all the apple
trees were
gone then our donkey brain friend spent
the rest of his life moaning and wailing
and screaming and crying and heeing and
hawing trying to figure out why there
were no more apples he couldn't
understand that it was all his fault he
couldn't understand much of anything
because he had the birn
brain of a
donkey who would have thought that one
donkey brained man could do so much
damage to the
world you know how some stories have a
moral a lesson a
takeaway hold that thought while we talk
about Professor Richard donkey excuse me
Dawkins Richard dcins has spent decades
attacking Christianity and yet he
prefers living in a Christian country
and considers himself a cultural
Christian we are culturally a Christian
country I'm I call myself a cultural
Christian I love hymns and Christmas
carols and I sort of feel at home in the
Christian ethos I feel that we are a
Christian country in that sense I would
not be happy if um for example we lost
all our Cathedrals and our beautiful
Parish churches so I I count myself a
cultural Christian if I had to choose
between Christianity and Islam I choose
Christianity every single time I mean it
seems to me to be a fundamentally decent
religion in so far as Christianity can
be seen as a bulock against Islam I
think it's it's a very good thing I mean
I find that I like to live in a
culturally Christian country in Africa
for example um where you have
missionaries of both faiths operating um
I'm I'm I'm on team Christian side it's
far as that's concerned nevertheless
even when he's right in the middle of
proclaiming that he prefers living in a
Christian country even when he's right
in the middle of declaring that he's a
cultural Christian he can't help but
attack Christianity and state how happy
he is that the number of people who
believe in Christianity in the UK is
declining uh it's truth that
statistically the number of people who
actually believe in Christianity is
going down and I I'm happy with that I
do not believe a single word of the
Christian faith I must emphasize that
that I think that that the the things
that Christians believe are actually
nonsense do you actually believe that
Jesus had a a virgin for a mother do you
actually believe he rose from the dead
do you believe that his mother was a was
a virgin I mean today is Easter and and
of course I don't believe that Jesus
rose from the dead I I don't want to be
misunderstood I mean I I do think it's
nonsense you loves the apples but can't
stand the apple tree speaking of trees
here's the parable of the Mustard Seed
in Matthew
13 He Jesus put another Parable before
them saying the Kingdom of Heaven is
like a grain of mustard seed that a man
took and sowed in his field it is the
smallest of all seeds but when it has
grown it is larger than all the garden
plants and becomes a tree so that the
birds of the air come and make nests in
its
branches Jesus said these words words in
the first half of the first century his
followers were a tiny group of Jews in a
tiny seemingly insignificant province of
the Roman Empire but he said that the
kingdom of heaven was like a mustard
seed tiny little seed that grows until
it becomes the size of a tree so big
that birds come and make nests in its
branches so Christianity is going to
start really small but become really big
that part's easy to understand
but what do the birds represent in the
parable small seed becomes a big tree
birds come and perch in the branches of
the tree what do the birds
symbolize there are two broad approaches
to interpreting Parables you can treat a
parable as an isolated story ignore
everything else read the parable and see
what the message is or you can treat it
as a story that's connected to other
stories or other teachings in the Bible
as a quick example the parable right
after the parable of the mustard seed is
the parable of the leaven he told them
another Parable the Kingdom of Heaven is
like leaven that a woman took and hid in
three measures of flour till it was all
leavened so leaven is something that
makes bread rise you add a little leaven
to the flower the leaven Works through
the dough and you end up with leavened
bread if you treat this Parable as an
isolated story not connected to anything
else you'd probably interpret the flower
as the world and the leaven as the
gospel or the church spreading through
the
world but if you connect this Parable to
the rest of the Bible it means something
totally different leev usually
symbolizes something negative in the New
Testament either false teaching as when
Jesus tells his followers to watch and
Beware of the leaven of the Pharisees
and
Sadducees or sin as when Paul warns the
Corinthians that A little leaven leavens
the whole
lump if you read the parable of the
leaven in light of other Bible passages
where leaven symbolizes something bad
you're probably going to interpret the
parable differently instead of the
leaven representing the gospel or the
church and the flower or representing
the world you might conclude that the
flower or dough represents the church
and that the leaven represents sin or
false teaching spreading into the church
so the message of the parable wouldn't
be that the church is going to spread
throughout the world the message would
be a warning that something bad is going
to work its way into the church now when
you look at the parable of the leaven
you might think think that the leaven
can't represent something bad because
Jesus says the Kingdom of Heaven is like
Levan the kingdom is like leevan how can
Levan be something bad but that's not
how the Parables work the kingdom isn't
like the first word that Jesus mentions
it's like the entire picture presented
in the story in other words when Jesus
says in Matthew 25 then the kingdom of
heaven will be like 10 virgins he's not
saying the Kingdom of Heaven is like 10
virgins he's saying it's like what
happens in the story the story tells you
something about the
Kingdom so when Jesus says the Kingdom
of Heaven is like leevan that a woman
took and hid in three measures of flower
till it was all
leavened is he saying that Christianity
or the church is going to spread
throughout the world or is he warning
his followers that something bad is
going to work its way into the
church all depends on whether you take
an isolated approach or an expanded
approach full disclosure I'm not opposed
to the idea that both interpretations
can be valid and that there can be
multiple layers of meaning in a parable
there can be a surface level meaning and
a deeper meaning Jesus said that we're
dealing with the secrets of the Kingdom
of Heaven here with this in mind let's
get back to those pesky birds in the
parable of the Mustard Seed the Kingdom
of Heaven is like a grain of mustard
seed that a man took and Seed in his
field it is the smallest of all seeds
but when it has grown it is larger than
all the garden plants and becomes a tree
so that the birds of the air come and
make nests in its
branches what do the birds
represent isolating the parable from
everything else the birds don't have to
represent anything the birds could just
be another way of emphasizing how big
the mustard plant
becomes or keeping the parable isolated
if we want to say that the birds
symbolize something we could say that
the birds symbolize people or groups
that are going to find shelter in the
kingdom of God along these lines some
commentators have suggested that the
birds represent Gentiles entering the
kingdom but what happens if we don't
treat the parable of the Mustard Seed as
an isolated story what if we look
outside the parable for a clue about
what the birds
represent interestingly Jesus talks
about birds in another Parable earlier
in the same chapter and he explains to
his disciples what the birds there
represent the parable of the sewer that
same day Jesus went out of the house and
sat beside the sea and great crowds
gathered about him so that he got into a
boat and sat down and the whole crowd
stood on the beach and he told them many
things and Parables saying a sewer went
out to sew and as he sewed some seeds
fell along the path and the birds came
and devoured them Jesus describes
different types of soil and how
different types of soil affect the
growth of the grain the path is hard
from people walking on it so the seeds
never enter the soil and birds come and
devour
them Jesus goes on to explain this
Parable he says Hear then the parable of
the sewer when anyone hears the word of
the kingdom and does not understand it
the evil one comes and snatches away
what has been sown in his heart this is
what was sown along the path so the
birds in the parable of the sewer
represent the forces of the evil one the
birds symbolize something bad opposition
to the gospel something that snatches
away the words of Jesus to keep people
from understanding them that's the
immediate context of the parable of the
Mustard Seed we have the birds in the
parable of the sewer a sewer went out to
sew and as he sewed some seeds fell
along the path and the birds came and
devoured them and then we have the birds
in the parable of the Mustard Seed the
birds of the air come and make nests in
its
branches if some of the negative meaning
carries over from one Parable to the
other and the birds in the parable of
the Mustard Seed represent the forces of
the evil one that snatch away the gospel
before people can understand it then
this Parable turns out to be a prophecy
about the enemies of the Kingdom the
Kingdom of Heaven is like a grain of
mustard seed that a man took and sowed
in his field the kingdom is going to
begin as something extremely small as
Christianity did in the first century it
is the smallest of all seeds but when it
has grown it is larger than all the
garden plants and becomes a tree kingdom
is is going to become the biggest plant
in the garden as Christianity did when
it grew and impacted the world so that
the birds of the air come and make nests
in its branches the kingdom is going to
become so big it's going to have such a
massive impact on the world that even
its enemies even those who oppose it
even those who can't stop attacking it
are going to be living in it they're the
ones who snatch away the gospel but
they're perched on the branches of the
Kingdom the enemies of the Gospel are
going to feel quite at home in the
Kingdom where did Richard dcins say he
feels at home I sort of feel at home in
the Christian ethos I feel that we are a
Christian country in that sense and yet
he just can't stop snatching the seeds I
must emphasize that that I think that
that that the things that Christians
believe are actually nonsense do you
actually believe that Jesus had a a
virgin for a mother do you actually
believe he rose from the dead do you
believe that his mother was a was a
virgin he loves the apples but hates the
tree he loves the fruit but hates the
root I do not believe a single word of
the Christian faith not even the parts
that tell you all about the situation
you're in right now Professor donkey
so Richard donkins and his followers are
the Smart Ones in all of this just ask
them they'll tell you who are the dumb
ones people who follow Jesus even though
2,000 years ago Jesus predicted the very
situation Richard donkins and his
followers find themselves in and Richard
donkins and his followers can't figure
out why the civilization they feel at
home in is falling apart all around them
and they can't stop blasting away at the
tree they're living in the new atheists
assured us that the more people turn
away from Christianity the more rational
people will become that was their
prophecy what actually happened well the
moment people in the west started
turning away from Christianity in large
numbers the entire Western world started
going completely insane
how can the new atheists be the Smart
Ones when they can't even see the
obvious how can people who live in a
tree think they're smart while chopping
down the tree they live in how can
people who like apples think they're
smart while declaring war on apple
trees how can people who live in a
forest think they're smart when they've
started a forest fire
we read multiple passages in Matthew 13
the parable of the sewer the parable of
the mustard seed and the parable of the
leaven but Jesus explained in the same
chapter the spiritual blindness of
people like Richard dongin and his
followers Jesus says this is why I speak
to them in Parables because seeing they
do not see and hearing they do not hear
nor do they understand indeed indeed in
their case the prophecy of Isaiah is
fulfilled that says you will indeed hear
but never understand and you will indeed
see but never perceive for this people's
heart has grown dull and with their ears
they can barely hear and their eyes they
have closed lest they should see with
their eyes and hear with their ears and
understand with their heart and turn and
I would heal them so my atheist
friends how you like them apples
[Music]